welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast i am your one and only full-time
permanent host eric trexler today i'm
joined by a very special but extremely
temporary guest co-host his name is greg
knuckles greg thanks for joining me yeah
thanks for uh thanks for taking the risk
of having me on how's your morning going
uh
it's going well um
let's see
friendsgiving is this afternoon it is so
uh
you know cooking last night cooking this
morning i like cooking so uh yeah makes
makes for a good morning it's a bold
choice trying to record this in the
morning we'll see how it goes
i mean it's not technically the morning
but it's it's the morning for me close
enough how is uh how's the start to your
day going uh good did a bunch of stuff
around the house uh
did a bunch of work this morning feeling
good feeling productive
um so before we get into the content for
today's episode we've got uh some big
announcements i think the biggest one
is that we've got a huge sale coming up
for mass
monthly applications and strength sport
that's our monthly research review
mass if you're not familiar it's 10
pieces of content per month but
starting this upcoming issue we've got
an enormous change that we're really
stoked about
so
greg you've been doing a
piece of content in math called research
briefs and it's where rather than doing
a full in-depth longer article it's more
concise summaries of
several studies with a real emphasis on
practical application
and so we have expanded the research
briefs segment of mass
and so that effectively doubles our
study coverage if you look at the first
issues of mass and you compare it to now
it's the same amount of total content
but we've basically doubled the number
of studies we cover on a monthly basis
so it's a pretty huge upgrade that we're
pretty excited about um
and that is going to coincide with our
big uh black friday sale which is our
biggest biggest sale of the year so
these are the lowest prices that you're
that you're going to see for mass during
our black friday sale
it uh by the way since it's a
subscription product we should clarify
when you subscribe at the sale price
you're locked into that sale price for
the life of your subscription you could
do monthly annual or lifetime
subscriptions if you're not sure if
you're ready to subscribe to mass you
can check out a free issue which i will
link in the notes of this show
and uh the sale the dates are from
november 22nd to november 29th and i
should of course point out this is a
charity sale so
uh if you do a monthly subscription
during the sale period a hundred percent
of your first month's payment will go to
the charity that we chose if you do an
annual or lifetime subscription 21
will go to the charity so
very very excited to uh hopefully raise
some money for a really good charity
this month
also if you want to support the show you
could subscribe to macro factor or you
could use the
the code sbs pod when you check out at
bulksupplements.com that was quite a
sales pitch and now we can move on with
the road to the stage segment
yeah uh so
i i made my notes for this last night
when i was putting the outline together
but i need to scrap them entirely
my notes last night were uh quote
nothing too exciting energy expenditure
has finally plateaued and gradual weight
loss has restarted
uh so you know that wouldn't be very
very exciting
um but this morning i was
236.4 which is officially more than 30
pounds down since i started using macro
factor nice and my previous low was like
237
point something so like ultimately it's
not that not that big of a difference uh
you know
human brain dealing with pounds and a
base to number system so
around like 10 pound increment
uh
achievement i guess
uh feels like a bigger deal
ultimately in the grand scheme of things
it's not really but it feels good to me
so um
yeah
things things were kind of plateaued for
a little bit uh weight was flat
and
my uh estimated energy expenditure had
trended down like 500 calories a day
over the span of a month
um
and turns out that seems to be
approximately correct now that i'm
eating uh quite a bit less than i was
approximately a month ago
weight loss has restarted uh and i have
uh
cleared that 30 pound milestone so
um yeah feel feel pretty good about
things nice it's i've seen
a lot of users that are a little bit
surprised when they have that reduction
in energy expenditure or the opposite
sometimes increases in energy
expenditure but it does go to show that
i mean total daily energy expenditure is
quite dynamic you know it's not a static
thing i think sometimes we think once we
get a good estimate for it's like
glad that's over with now i know my
energy expenditure but yeah it is
dynamic and it will change yeah like
we'll we'll occasionally see threads
that's just like man
over the last month my estimated energy
expenditure has gone up over
two like
it's gone up 200 calories over the last
month so
what have i done wrong in the app to
lead it to
miss estimate my energy expenditure by
200 calories and it's just like
maybe it actually went up by 200
calories yeah but yeah it's uh
very dynamic and unfortunately mine is
currently being dynamic in the direction
that i would not like it to be but yeah
you know that's that's the way the
cookie crumbles and ultimately like i
said on the last episode of the podcast
uh it's good to know because
traditionally
i've gotten down to about this weight or
slightly heavier than i currently am hit
a wall just kind of get frustrated and
say yeah [ __ ] it who cares about cutting
i'm just gonna i'm just gonna get strong
again
um but you know now actually being able
to see the numbers and seeing like oh
okay like i do actually need to pretty
substantially cut calories at this point
uh and being able to do so in a
controlled way instead of just saying
like well
you know
what seemed like a moderate level of
calorie intake wasn't working so let's
just you know let's just go into like
uh
protein sparing modified fast like you
know i i didn't have to resort to
extreme measure so
you know ultimately i'm slightly annoyed
with my body about all of this but uh
overall in the grand scheme of things uh
i'd say it's going pretty well yeah like
you said it's good to know i think one
of the most demotivating factors when it
comes to weight loss in many cases is
just
doubt and uncertainty so it is nice to
see a number to see a graph even if it's
giving you information that you're not
exactly thrilled about it's better to
have the information than not have it
yeah
all right moving on uh the road to
enlightenment is pivoting
um for two reasons it is now the road to
athens which is a tremendously exciting
announcement so
the road to enlightenment uh is ending
for two reasons first of all that person
in the facebook group finally convinced
you that it was just cultural
appropriation not quite but
so
in my defense since i rolled out this
segment i fully acknowledge i have no
idea where it's going or what to do with
it i think it has reached its only
logical conclusion which is me being
asked to actually
say substantive things about secular
buddhism that i'm fully unqualified to
talk about uh
for once i do accept responsibility for
that
i don't know how else this could have
played out uh and yeah it's time to move
on plus
i'd say that's an important stepping
stone on your road to enlightenment yeah
the second reason that i'm pivoting from
the road to i'm still doing
i'm still
engaged with this endeavor in my life
i'm just not talking about it anymore
unless someone asks me but uh another
thing to keep in mind is a lot of folks
are saying that i did in fact already
reach enlightenment so
as we talked about uh by the lake i
either passed out or became enlightened
there's
a lot of debate i'll let the scholars
kind of sort that out over the next few
hundred years but for now i'm
transitioning and i'm getting on to the
road to athens
and the uh the reason it's the road to
athens the first ever marathon
was as the story goes from marathon to
athens
apparently people debate exactly how
long a marathon should be i was reading
an article about it but the modern
interpretation is 26.2 miles and i think
i do have my set my sights set on the
goal of running a marathon in the
relatively near future i'm thinking
possibly late spring if i can swing it
um i will admit that i cheated i got
back into running before i you know have
made this announcement so
the reason i cheated is i have failed so
many times getting back into running and
i always fail at the earliest stage
and the reason i fail
is because i get really really into it
and i usually have a lower extremity
injury that will get me you know so i
can't just ease into running i just say
hey i like running and then i run way
too much and usually it's my right
planner fascia but it's it's always
either a foot or a knee that will get me
because i just do too much too fast i
don't have the
i have all the motivation all the focus
and none of the discipline to rein
myself in so
i am and you also
without running just stay in weirdly
good shape
that that so that's a true thing is that
uh because like in
the this is on topic like when
we were kind of in that weird
phase business-wise when you had
graduated in december and i was still
doing the last year of my master's um
you know so like the stronger by science
partnership wasn't like
fully operational yet because i was
mostly just in the lab all the time uh
you were just like hey i have all of
this additional time on my hands i'm
gonna get into running again and i
remember you saying like oh man i just
started running again this week i love
it feels good uh went for a 15 mile run
three days ago went for a 12 mile run
yesterday like yeah this is awesome i
love it and so like one i was thinking
like that's ridiculous like i would need
to train for six months to be able to
run 15 miles uh so [ __ ] this guy for
being able to jump right into it and the
second thing i was thinking is like
dude going from
you know say what you will about acute
on chronic workload ratios there's some
debate about how predictive of injury
risk that is but if that idea holds any
merit at all
the acute to chronic workload ratio of
zero miles per week to
whatever the [ __ ] you were doing i was
just like i i don't know it doesn't seem
like a great idea to me but uh good luck
dude
the next week i asked you like how's
your running doing you're like man i
have a really bad case of plantar
fasciitis yeah i was like dude that was
that's completely out of the out of the
blue who could have predicted it right
so so the problem is like like you said
um
for whatever reason i i do think that
i'm
uh naturally more inclined for endurance
activity rather than strength or power
activity
um and so the problem is i'll get back
into running my cardiovascular system
you know
i'm i can handle it like my my cardio
respiratory fitness is like ready to go
but my lower extremities are not ready
to handle the pounding um so this time
around i didn't really you know
talk about getting back into running
until i had gotten through that initial
phase of getting my mostly my feet able
to handle the mileage that the rest of
my body was ready for
so this time getting back into it i
started it at a time when i was pretty
busy which is good because even when i
wanted to go out for a ridiculous run
like dude who's got the time you know so
that was good i also uh you know did a
little bit of cold water immersion so
you know you've covered that in mass
before
and uh
there are potential downsides of you
know if you're regularly doing post
exercise cold water immersion you could
attenuate some of your training
adaptations you know for me
mitochondrial biogenesis is the last
thing on my mind when i'm getting into
running for the reasons i just mentioned
you know those molecular level cardiova
cardio respiratory adaptations to
support endurance i don't really need
those yet i will but my biggest obstacle
when i'm getting into it is can i put in
mileage and keep my feet and my knees
feeling okay so that's why i kind of
made that trade-off and you know my
advice when you're getting into
something like this is
when you're in that entry level stage
abandon optimal and focus more closely
on what your specific obstacles are and
challenges are so if you know going into
a dietary change or a training change or
something like that what your primary
obstacle is you should be tailoring your
approach to what that is so for me
mitochondrial adaptations i'll take care
of them later the top priority was
easing back into this and staying
healthy managing my acute recovery from
session to session so that would be my
general advice that would apply to many
different endeavors is don't worry about
optimal right out of the gate
focus on your biggest obstacle and
that's been the thing that's been
dictating my recovery practices and my
mileages and my frequency of running is
what can basically my right foot handle
and so far so good i'm really stoked
about it so uh this is a great
transition for
segments because i actually do feel
comfortable talking about this which is
good that's usually
kind of a prerequisite for a podcast
segment so i do feel good about talking
about this new endeavor into endurance
sport uh we're not gonna rename the
company
you know uh
what would be a different play on
stronger by science we're not shifting
to a cardio focused company or podcast
but i am gonna pepper a little bit of
cardio content in there
can i just say something really quick
about marathons before we move on sure
because i i saw the snippet of the
article you posted in the outline uh
and got slightly upset like th this is
one of the
many things that i'm that i'm somewhat
annoyed about um
when when people bring up a particular
anecdote that i'm like oh no that's
actually not right uh so anyway well i
didn't say it so i haven't i'm not
accepting responsibility for this didn't
uh i just want to share a fun fact with
the audience about marathons okay so
this article you have in the outline
starts with uh in a nod to greek history
the first marathon commemorated the run
of the soldier fediputes from a
battlefield near the town of marathon
greece to athens and 490 bc according to
legend fedipides ran the approximately
25 miles to announce the defeat of the
persians to some anxious athenians not
quite in mid-season shape that's the
thing i'm going to quibble with he
delivered the message nike or victory
and then keeled over and died so that's
that's like the story of the marathon
that uh for whatever reason has made it
to the modern day
and actually that version of the
marathon story has had some
interesting
sociocultural effects so uh like that's
one of the reasons that people think
that um
in so i'm i'm going to sound like
uh [ __ ] here oh cool but that's one
of the reasons why i think people think
that it's a huge accomplishment to even
finish a marathon and like
it's not that that's
a small accomplishment but i think
people overstate how huge of a deal it
is and i think part of that you're gonna
get destroyed for saying that sure i i'm
sure i will i mean i've
look man
i've walked more than 25 miles in a day
before have you really yes
oh wow uh yeah on a
trip to new york city like we were there
with friends we were seeing the sights
and uh
like i mean i'm sure it wasn't a
perfectly precise estimate but like the
step counter at the end of the day
pegged us at like 27 miles yeah i do get
i was [ __ ] dead at the end of the day
but like i i do get your point and i
have talked to people who have done
marathons without training yeah yeah so
like that that kind of supports your
general idea there so people think that
it's a huge huge deal because the idea
is like oh this guy ran
about 25 miles and died at the end of it
uh and the other like socio-cultural
effect that i have in mind
is like this was one of the reasons why
women weren't allowed to run marathons
until like kind of recently i think the
70s
um
man i'm blanking on her name but there's
a really good story about the first
woman to run the boston marathon and how
like the race organizers tried to
actively grab her and pull her off of
the course because the the thinking was
like man a marathon is very grueling and
the delicate female body simply can't
handle this like if it could kill
fedipides it's definitely going to kill
a woman like th that
that was like
part of the thinking there
but anyway so uh
that would all be well and good if the
full marathon story was fidipides you
know he's this messenger guy he's just
kind of chilling at the battlefield and
then when the victory is is won he runs
back to athens tells people and dies
like i i think that's kind of the
the image people have in mind when they
think the marathon story but that's not
the full story within
depending who you talk to greek history
or greek mythology like the the battle
definitely occurred but how accurate the
telling is like who knows but uh anyway
the full fedipity story
is the persians were coming they were
supposed to land at marathon
and uh the athenians were just like
well [ __ ] we might be overmatched here
we need to see if the spartans will be
willing to help us out so
uh fedipides was like the courier of the
athenian military i'm sure they had
several but like he was i guess the best
one so he ran from uh athens to sparta
which was i think like 70 75 miles i
don't know greek geography but like he
ran a long ass way to sparta yeah and
said like hey guys can you help us out
and if memory serves they said nah [ __ ]
you like we don't care um and so then
he had to run from sparta to marathon
um to deliver the news to the army like
hey we're gonna have to do this
ourselves we can't rely on the spartans
to to come bail us out
so he ran
from athens to sparta from sparta to
marathon then he fought the battle of
marathon which
i assume was physically taxing yeah and
then he ran about 25 miles back to
athens okay and then keeled over at the
end of it so like
so you're saying i should do an ultra
marathon i'm saying my road to athens
i'm saying you should run
75 75
25 you should run like 175 miles with
like four to six hours of simulated
combat in the middle and then die
well i think that
might occur okay but but anyway so
yeah the the thing about fedipity's
dying at the end of the whole process if
that is true like if that is a true
historical account and he died after
delivering the message it wasn't
simply after running the marathon it was
after
you know putting in like
close to 200 miles of running and
fighting a battle yeah that's that's
more than i'm ready for yeah uh but like
i said i'll i'll be providing some
updates on my marathon training uh but
it's not going to become endurance by
science or anything like that it's still
going to be a strength focus and with
that in mind what's up with feats of
strength
yeah i've just got one this week
partially because there aren't that many
competitions going on currently and uh
partially because i
didn't feel like looking around all that
much
um but the one i have is very cool
so uh
i know i'm gonna butcher this name i
assume it's maric zeik
zych
set the new all-time world record
deadlift
in the 90 kilogram class or 198 pound
class he deadlifted 406 kilos or uh 895
pounds so
you know for for people dealing in
freedom units he's very close to
deadlifting over 900 pounds at a sub 200
body weight
which is which is wild to me
um
and also you should go watch the video
it's one of the
i think it's going to be a polarizing
video i love it it's a
beautifully technically efficient sumo
deadlift from a guy who's built for sumo
deadlifts yeah we're talking
minimal range of motion
uh
pure economy of movement
um
and i i think that's incredible because
to me powerlifting is about moving away
from a to b in whatever way the rules
allow which is exactly what he did uh i
think some
some sumo is cheating people will
use the video as like ammo for their
argument but
honestly i don't care i think it's sick
uh so congrats to him
yeah i saw that and uh it's
as efficient as a deadlift could
possibly be uh really really impressive
stuff him and uh
uh nasanov i think are
are the two most efficient sumo
deadlifters right now oh one question i
had for you on this uh particular
uh segment
someone messaged me i guess have you
heard that usapl is like going back to
old weight classes
yes so someone asked me what my opinion
was on that and of course i have none
but i'm pitching it to you oh i've i've
got an opinion on this
um
so i'm not going to talk about all of
the usapl ipf drama
um
i think i think my opinion is somewhere
in the middle i think if you had to say
one or the other is in the right like
just a purely binary thing i think the
usapl is more in the right than the ipf
but i also think
their
messaging about why they got kicked out
of the ipf is
slightly dishonest so anyway i i think
if i shared my full thoughts on the
matter i just make people mad so i'm
gonna forgo that yeah um but i am stoked
about reverting to the old weight
classes for a couple of reasons
one i [ __ ] hate the new weight
classes i think they're stupid um
like
i don't know dude
we're humans our brains like nice round
numbers and even increments between
things
and i felt like just some of the weight
classes themselves and the jumps between
weight classes they felt kind of random
and also
i don't know i didn't love the fact that
the ipf and its affiliates went with one
weight class system which differed from
their history and differed from every
other powerlifting federation in the
world like
you know the old weight classes weren't
broke don't try to fix them so that was
kind of my my boomer perspective when
the new weight classes were rolled out
several years ago uh but reverting to
the old weight classes i like because i
i view it as a return to tradition
um
and also much more importantly the thing
i like about the new weight classes is
they added back
the
140 kilo class for men
and they added um
i know they added in a 100 kilo class i
think they added a 110 class for women
as well
uh and i think that's pretty huge for a
couple of reasons
one is
um
there are
so with the old weight classes for men
it cut off at 120 and for women it cut
off at 84.
and
there are a lot of people who are into
powerlifting who are
bigger than 120 or 264
who
probably don't want to get up into
the mid 300s to really be competitive in
the super heavyweight class
and that was
that was the case for women as well to
an
enormously larger degree yeah like the
gap there like that that second highest
weight class yeah
in the female category was insane like
84 kilos isn't that big for women um
i mean like that's
what that's like slightly higher than
the population average so like yeah
going from 84 kilos to super heavy
weight it's a big jump i i thought that
that was pretty [ __ ] so i think that
adding the 140 class for men
is a small improvement from kind of
going from 120 to super heavy and i
think adding the 100 and 110
kilo class for women i think that's huge
like i i think that that
um
i think that that will meet the needs of
a lot of people who
you know didn't want to be sub 120 or
sub 84 but
you know didn't want to do what you got
to do
to be a top super heavyweight
um
so yeah i
am fully supportive of
the old slash new usapl weight classes
uh the the one
the one uh kind of weight class jump
that i've seen some people complaining
about is with the reversion to the old
weight classes now it jumps from 60
kilos to 67 and a half
and i think some people think that
that's kind of a big jump and that maybe
there should be
one more intermediate weight class there
but
i don't know to me i think the the pros
outweigh the cons yeah but also i'm
never gonna sniff 60 kilos so yeah it's
it's easy for me to say that it doesn't
matter that much
yeah yeah i i think overall the
positives outweigh the negatives nice
all right so
i have a very brief tech support segment
here uh if you're new to the show tech
support is where we talk a little bit
about our diet app called macro factor
just kind of reminders
in this particular tech support segment
the base of users in macro factor is
growing which is fantastic of course we
sincerely appreciate all the support
and
our macro factory users by the way we do
call them mfers and and that's uh
a very simple uh abbreviation that
couldn't possibly be misconstrued so
thanks to all the mfers out there who
are supporting us
uh a couple things just reminders to
people who might be new to the app or
who are thinking about checking checking
it out um we've put a lot of content
into
stronger by science articles about the
app talking about how it was developed
the general concept uh kind of our
philosophy behind the product we've also
put a ton of information a ton of
content into what we call the knowledge
base and the knowledge base you can
access it uh you know through your
internet browser on your computer
um or you can access it right in the app
there's little buttons you can hit to uh
to get some extra information so
mo you know a lot of the uh startup
questions when you start using the app
if you check out the knowledge base
you'll not just get the
answer you know not just the you know
quick answer of how to do it but also
the thought process behind
why the app functions the way it does so
if you're getting into the app
definitely encourage you to check out
our articles and our knowledge-based
content about the app um now we are
obviously a very young company the app
when did the app get launched
it feels like two weeks ago but it was
probably like i think september 22nd
okay something like that but uh anyway
you know
it's it we're a young company it's a
pretty new app but we've already rolled
out a lot of feature updates and uh you
know users already know that we
massively expanded our food database
which has been huge for our users in the
uk australia ireland new zealand
it also seems to be bolstering our
barcode support in other regions outside
of those but those are the regions that
have gotten a
huge uptick in terms of their barcode
coverage
um and we do have more plans for the
future when it comes to database
expansion but we've made a bunch of
updates and uh you know additional
features in our short time in operation
but now the big uh
the big piece of news i guess is that we
have a public road map now so
users or you know people who are
thinking about becoming users can not
just check out the app with the free
trial but they can also look at where
the app is headed in the future so i
will put the link for our public roadmap
in the show notes here but it's a place
where users can submit feature requests
it's also a place where you can vote on
you know which requests you find to be
most helpful or most interesting so it's
an opportunity to kind of have some say
on
the future development roadmap for macro
factors so
it gives you an opportunity not just to
keep an eye on our vision for the future
but to actually influence that potential
trajectory so
if you're interested in the app or
you're already a user like i said i'll
put that link and you can check out the
public roadmap and if you don't want to
look at the show notes the url is
feedback.macrofactorapp.com
in just one note if you check out the
public roadmap it's not uh fully
comprehensive for
all of the
things people have suggested and
certainly not comprehensive of all of
the features we plan to deliver down the
line think of it as kind of a short to
medium term road map uh i'm not going to
put a
distinct time number
on that um
but yeah so we we have
huge plans for features we want to roll
out over a matter of years but if you
check out the roadmap um
you know those are things that are kind
of
actively in the research and development
stage
absolutely okay moving on we've got a
research review segment uh greg you're
going to be talking about cooling gloves
and we this is a something that we've
been getting a lot of questions about so
i'm excited for you to cover this so
that we can just link to it in the
future yeah so i know
exactly why we've been getting a lot of
questions about about this um
i
unless i am horribly mistaken it's due
to craig heller's appearance on the
hubermann lab podcast
which i'm not going to comment directly
on but i'm simply going to provide
an overview of the cooling literature so
you know research looking into does
intra exercise cooling
affect uh performance so
let's dive into this so for
the
areas of the research that are probably
a little bit less relevant to
podcasts or stronger by science podcast
listeners but the areas where there are
the most research
there was a systematic review and
meta-analysis
that came out i believe last year by
doozy and colleagues title was cooling
during exercise enhances performances
but the cooled body areas matter a
systematic review and meta-analysis
uh and so what what uh this was looking
at was all of the crossover studies that
investigated the effects of um
pre-exercise but mostly intra exercise
cooling protocols uh on performance and
just based on the inclusion criterias
they used um
they didn't end up including any of the
studies that existed on resistance
training so i'm going to talk about all
of those separately
but broadly the
studies were split two ways one was
studies looking at aerobic performance
and the other was studies looking at
anaerobic performance so say like
repeated sprint ability
um
and cooling seemed to significantly
improve aerobic performance with a
uh pretty hefty moderate effect size uh
pooled effect estimate uh was a cohen's
d of about .6 which you know that's
that's a pretty notable effect um just
to put that in context the impact of
caffeine on
really basically every outcome is
somewhere between an effect size of
about 0.2 to 0.4 that's that's for
maximal strength strength endurance
power aerobic performance caffeine seems
to have a small but positive effect on
virtually everything
so for aerobic performance
the effect size of interac
of intra exercise cooling seemed to be
about twice the effect size of caffeine
so you know notable but not like a night
and day difference and is that
specifically hand cooling no no no so
that's uh all of the cooling
interventions they looked at so
um you know
like a neck wrap or
uh palm cooling or like a full body
cooling suit or um
one of the things that seemed to be
pretty effective was just drinking cold
beverages because ultimately
the the thing that
when
overheating becomes problematic for
aerobic performance
the the thing that's really going to get
you is when core temperature starts
elevating and so if you just like drink
a really cold beverage or like eat some
crushed ice that cools you centrally um
so that that seems to be fairly
effective honestly so back in the day
i remember uh like coaches and athletic
trainers saying that like you're
supposed to drink like lukewarm or room
temperature liquids because like if you
drink cold liquid
when you're really exerting yourself
it's gonna like put you into shock or
something or like divert blood to your
intestines instead of your muscles
i don't think there's any evidence for
that i think that's a myth but anyway
these are the same people who
told us that we couldn't possibly
recover with our hands on our knees that
is that is also true yeah anyway uh so
that's that seems to be fake just
drinking cold stuff
seems seems to be good
anyway so yeah for aerobic exercise a
a
moderate but
uh pretty noteworthy effect
for anaerobic exercise the effect size
was
still statistically significant but
quite a bit smaller so pool effect
estimate of about 0.27
which is a positive effect but it's
worth noting that when they were looking
at
kind of the study conditions or cooling
protocols used
they found that the most effective was
whole body cooling garments and that
cooling only seemed to be effective for
anaerobic performance when you were
doing anaerobic stuff under hot
conditions so they operationally define
that as greater than 28 degrees celsius
which i think is somewhere in like the
mid to high 80s but
i don't know i'm relatively comfortable
with most aspects of the metric system i
don't [ __ ] know celsius though
fahrenheit to celsius and vice versa is
a nightmare yeah here's another hot take
i mostly like the metric system i like
you know centimeters and meters more
than like feet and yards and certainly
kilometers more than miles uh
i like uh grams and kilos more than
ounces and pounds uh i like
uh milliliters and liters more than
[ __ ] tablespoons and cups and
whatever else
um
but
i do think
that outside of scientific purposes i
think fahrenheit is better than celsius
like yeah i understand like oh okay like
you're you're anchoring it with zero
being the freezing point and a hundred
being the boiling point so though those
numbers are
pegged to something meaningful when
you know when you're doing experiments
or something like that but just for
day-to-day use i think the benefit of
um i think the benefit of fahrenheit
is just that like 10 degree increments
kind of mean something like if
in i feel like that helps with
communication i suppose like if someone
were to say and celsius like ah it's
gonna be in the 30s today it's either
gonna be
pretty hot or like the hottest day
you've ever experienced
or if they say like ah it's gonna be in
the in the tens it could be pretty
comfortable could be fairly cold if you
say in fahrenheit like ah today's in the
50s doesn't matter if it's 51 or 59 like
it's it's the 50s same sweatshirt yeah
um
and i also i also think it's
i don't know i i think it's good for
um
you know what i'm not i'm not gonna get
off on that tangent we're talking about
body cooling right now anyway mostly
like the metric system but i i'm a
fahrenheit ride-or-die guy yeah i was
gonna say you said before we started
recording like hey let's make sure we
keep this one really tight you know keep
it on a short timeline here
and then you know six minutes into
talking about fahrenheit versus celsius
well you know what man i actually am
well rested for once i have the
appropriate amount of stimulants in my
system i didn't wake up five minutes
before we started recording so i'm fully
prepared to be on my [ __ ] today yeah
um
much more loquacious than i typically
would be then i'll i'll take um i'll
take on the task of
reigning you back in now it's fine okay
so let's get back on topic so that
that's the meta-analysis uh
notable moderate effect for aerobic
performance smaller moderate effect for
um
or no that's a small effect so a small
effect for anaerobic performance
and those effects really only seem to
show up when you're testing in pretty
hot conditions
okay so let's move on to the resistance
training studies um
there's a study by bacon and colleagues
titled effect of two recovery methods on
repeated closed-handed and open-handed
weight-assisted pull-ups
and so this was a study in climbers
where they were looking at pull-up
performance um
closed-handed pull-ups are what they
sound like um so you know you're just
grabbing the pull-up bar as one would
grab a pull-up bar
i think open-handed pull-ups was kind of
like fingertip pull-ups um
anyway so they they had a cooling
intervention uh it was ice bags applied
i think to the arms and shoulders
between sets and also this was just a
weird study um i think there were like
17 minutes between sets but anyway they
found that uh
between set cooling protocols improved
open open hand pull-up performance but
not like normal pull-up performance so
you know maybe a small positive effect
there
moving on study by galosa and colleagues
resistance exercise inter intercept
cooling strategy effect on performance
and muscle damage so in this study they
had
two
they had two groups uh perform four sets
of bicep curls at eighty percent of one
rm uh one group uh had
ice ice bags applied to their biceps
between groups and the other herb
between sets and the other group didn't
and the cooling group was able to
complete more reps across the four sets
about 21 more
than the control group though
since this was a
you know
since it was an experimental study with
two groups instead of a crossover study
it's hard to know if that effect was due
to cooling per se or just potentially
differences between groups um
then a study by caruso
intermittent palm cooling's impact on
resistive exercise performance in this
study they had subjects do four sets of
eight um
like
uh yeah leg press so they had they did
four sets of eight leg press with a
flywheel device so for that you're not
necessarily doing reps to failure
because with the flywheel you can you
can just keep going you'll just move
slower and slower so they were looking
at decrements and power set to set and
in this study there were two cooling
conditions and one control condition
and over the first three sets
power output was comparable between
groups and the drop-off set to set was
about the same between groups but then
for the fourth set the two cooling
groups maintained performance a little
bit better and there was a slightly
larger drop-off for the control group
so over three sets
between set cooling didn't seem to do
much on the fourth set maybe it helped
with performance maintenance and then
finally there were two studies by
quan and colleagues and these were the
same study but one was done in males and
one was done in females in both of the
studies
the training protocol or the the testing
protocol was four sets of bench press to
failure at 85
of 1rm
and they had three conditions they had a
control condition they had a palm
heating condition and they had a palm
cooling condition um and these studies i
think used uh like a cooling glove type
setup so the the temperatures they used
um seemed comparable to the cooling
glove that now people are talking about
uh and also it was a negative pressure
thing so that's
one of the things that uh is supposed to
be special about the cooling glove you
put your hand in the glove negative
pressure maybe that pulls more blood in
uh that you can then exchange
temperature from helps with central
central cooling a little bit better um
so anyway it seemed to be the right type
of device to
look at the effects of a cooling glove
on performance uh but yeah there was a
heating and a cooling condition here and
so in the study in males
the uh the palm cooling condition
subjects completed
significantly more volume than the
control condition or the palm heating
condition
although
subjects also performed
non-significantly more reps in the palm
heating condition than the control
condition and then in the study on
females the palm heating and palm
cooling conditions outperformed the
control condition with no difference
between the heating and cooling
conditions which
opens up the possibility that
the impact the the small positive impact
that we're seeing in these resistance
training studies could potentially be a
placebo effect because
if uh if elevations in say core
temperature or muscle temperature
are negatively impacting the maintenance
of performance across multiple sets
then
you know cooling might be beneficial and
one would assume that heating would be
detrimental so
if we're seeing
two studies where heating certainly
isn't detrimental and in one of the
studies heating is just as ergogenic as
cooling is
but the difference there is for the
heating and cooling condition
you know some temperature thing is being
done to your hand versus the control
condition where nothing is being done to
your hand that opens up the possibility
that both of those effects could just be
a placebo effect like the
the subjects recognize like an
intervention is being done to me
generally in research you assume
interventions are effective therefore
this must be a good thing and
you know placebo effects stuff so
uh anyway looking at these five studies
you see
generally positive effects generally not
particularly large um
potentially all placebo who's to say but
you know one one could make either an
optimistic or a pessimistic case from
these studies that i've discussed
then there is
one more study
work volume and strength training
responses to resistive exercise improve
with periodic heat extraction from the
palm
by gran and colleagues one of those
colleagues is craig heller who was the
senior author on this paper and was a
recent guest on the hubermann lab
podcast
so i will note uh in the interest of
charity
that all of the studies i've discussed
up to this point we're looking at the
impact
of cooling interventions on acute
performance and this is the only one i'm
aware of looking at the impact
of cooling on longitudinal training
outcomes so it very well could be a
situation where
for reasons that haven't been discovered
yet
uh you know maybe it only has a small
effect acutely but chronically uh it
does something to improve responsiveness
to training
that is a possibility uh but
i'll i'll get into this the the results
of this study uh kind of stick out like
a sore thumb from
the rest of the cooling literature
so there were
there were like
five distinct studies talked about in
this paper there were a couple acute
studies and
i think three longitudinal studies um
[Music]
and quite simply i don't have time to
talk about all of it but i want to talk
about uh actually there were four
longitudinal studies i want to talk
about three of the four
so two of them were pull-up
interventions and one of them was a
bench press intervention so uh the first
pull-up intervention
um was on untrained subjects oh actually
just just to note uh for all for all of
these interventions or for the two
pull-up interventions uh there were
three minutes between sets for all sets
uh and all sets were performed to
failure and it's noted uh people were
doing uh chin-ups or pull-ups um but
they they had to actually be real
pull-ups like the chin had to get all
the way above the bar so
um
when you're listening to these results
you can't just
assume like oh maybe they were only
doing half reps or
i mean maybe they were but according to
the methods of the paper they were doing
real pull-ups getting their chin above
the bar every time did they have a
criteria for the
bottom of the pull-up that they
mentioned do you happen to remember
uh
if there was one they didn't mention it
so you'd have to anyway
one would assume if if you were doing uh
rigorous research that
you would try to make people go pretty
close to all the way down anyway so in
the first pull-up study
there were
subjects with at least two years of
prior resistance training experience and
they performed 10 sets of pull-ups uh
per per workout
um
and uh
so
they they did pull-ups with palm cooling
for six weeks
and uh they kind of split the group into
two so
um
one half of the group did six weeks of
palm cooling pull-ups followed by a
couple weeks of pull-ups without palm
cooling and for the other half it was
the opposite approach so they did
a period of pull-up training without
palm cooling followed by a period of
pull-up training with palm cooling
but kind of
pulling that all together
when during the six weeks of palm
cooling pull-up training
subjects improved their total work
volume across 10 sets by
144 percent
on average over six weeks
versus uh four percent um when they were
doing the same uh training protocol
without palm cooling
and uh it's worth noting
the
the
kind of absolute improvements uh during
the palm cooling period um for for
pull-ups across 10 sets
so when people began uh the protocol
they were they could do 134 plus or
minus 48 pull-ups across 10 sets so
average about 13 percent and that that
range was 70 to 153
then after six weeks of uh pull-ups with
palm cooling
uh they
averaged 298 plus or minus 168
with a range from 70 to
616 reps
so
their their average number across 10
sets increased from 13.4 to almost 30
and there was apparently one individual
who completed
616 reps of pull-ups
across 10 sets to failure with three
minutes between sets so that's that's
all very interesting
and then the average rate of performance
uh improvement was 13 pull-ups per
workout so about 1.3 pull-ups per set
improvement
during the palm cooling period versus
three uh during the
not cooling period
so okay uh moving on to the second study
uh or the the second i guess trial
within the single paper this was also a
pull-up study but it was using uh
recreational
recreational athletes naive to the
pull-up exercise so people who had never
done pull-ups before
and these people also did six weeks of
pull-up training with the cooling glove
and then a period of pull-up training
without the cooling glove
um and the rate of performance
improvement with the cooling glove was
1.7
pull-ups per workout versus .6 pull-ups
per workout without the cooling glove
um
so i find that kind of interesting uh so
of of note they were doing six sets here
um
but anyway i find this interesting
because
there were
basically two pull-up studies that were
very similar one in trained subjects and
one in untrained subjects and the
untrained or and the trained subjects
improved their number of pull-ups per
workout at like
per set
at like 4.5 times the rate as the
untrained subjects which
i don't know uh
you know
sometimes you just have a very
responsive group of athletes uh but
generally you assume that untrained
people will respond to training better
than trained people will
but the trained people here on a per set
basis were improving their performance
at like four and a half times the rate
uh the untrained people were
um which is interesting
anyway moving on to the bench press
study here
they initially enrolled 24 subjects only
10 of the 24 completed
uh the the training program
eight subjects dropped out for personal
reasons and then six subjects dropped
out because they weren't at a stable
plateau during the control phase of the
study and so you might hear that and be
like wait what are you talking about so
basically
what they did here
is they recruited people and they said
hey enroll in this study if you're at a
plateau in your bench press like you've
been training the bench press for a
while you can't get any stronger you're
at a plateau
and then what they did is they put them
on a standardized training protocol
and over
over a four week period
they they had them trained twice per
week and basically
if a subject experienced a measurable
improvement in performance over that
four-week lead-in period they kicked
them out of the study uh they said like
no you're not actually at a bench press
plateau we want to make sure that
everyone who is about to experience the
power of the cooling glove is
actually at a plateau for bench press
strength
so they did that they kicked out
everyone who was still capable of
improving their bench press without the
cooling glove
and then they
underwent six weeks of training with the
cooling glove um
and in six weeks of training doing two
bench press workouts per week they
improved their bench press 1rms by about
14
um
which is which is very cool like
for for a long time my my bench press
was plateaued just south of 500 pounds
it was like
475 to 485 depending on the day
i would love
to
be able to put about 65 to 70 pounds on
my bench in six weeks um i would be
very interested in a
intervention a non-pharmacological
intervention that would allow me to do
that
as i assume most people would be
so that's cool if something like that
existed i would love to know about it i
would love to use it i assume most other
lifters and athletes would as well and
if something were truly that effective i
i would expect uh
a lot of people to be using it and you
know maybe like every professional
sports team and every olympic athlete if
uh
if something did actually work that well
so anyway to sum all of this up we have
an entire body of literature showing
moderate effects for aerobic exercise
smaller but still significant effect for
anaerobic exercise but
of note only in hot conditions
um
and several studies showing small
positive effects for multi-set strength
endurance which again
may be attributable just to placebo
effects it's hard to say
and then you have one study in this body
of literature where uh
you know you have people doing 60
pull-ups per set for 10 sets you have
untrained lifters making strength gains
four and a half times faster than
trained lifters or people you flip that
i think trained making it yes where
train lifters make uh strength uh pull
up progress four and a half times faster
than untrained people
uh where people who are at a verified
plateau uh add 14 to their bench press
in six weeks um
and uh yeah i i find all of that very
interesting so um
you know do with that what you will
i'll be charitable and simply state that
this one study is a clear outlier within
this body of literature um and i
personally found some of the results of
the study to be quite perplexing
and i
don't know
that i would use
that study to
strongly inform my
perception of the potential impact of
cooling on
exercise performance so
i'll i'll leave it at that that's that's
my opinion on this question uh for the
next time that it's asked and here's a
fun tidbit seeing as uh one of the
subjects in this study did
uh
618 pull-ups across 10 sets averaging
more than 60 percent uh trex you want to
take a guess at what the world record
for most pull-ups in a minute is
uh i can't because i can see the outline
already cheated it's 68 so anyway
it's uh it's very cool that um someone's
keeping that up over 10 sets
that's uh
you know i'm i'm proud of that guy and i
wish he would have uh
you know hit up guinness and said yeah
hey i can i can set this record
cool i think you did a great job with
that i think that's very informative and
hopefully we'll never have to answer
that question again presented as
neutrally as possible um
yeah good stuff yeah let's let's move on
let us this is the second time we've
tried to record this and i think you did
a great job with it i think that i did
better this time around yes um all right
so
i've got uh kind of a different segment
here uh it's not one of our typical
recurring segment but i am uh
temporarily calling it contextualized
clarifications a bit of an alliteration
there so
sometimes we
are talking about fitness stuff right
and so we're answering a question in a
specific context or talking about a
topic in a very specific context
but it can lead to unintended
applications or
it might overstate significance when
it's carried into other contexts and
that sounds
very vague but you'll kind of see what
i'm getting at here uh i basically have
three topics that i want to provide some
additional context or clarification
just because
you know i've talked about them in one
specific scenario
and i feel different about them
potentially in other scenarios so the
first one i want to talk about
is
really low calorie diets okay so
um in the fitness world
i think there's a little bit of sticker
shock that occurs when people on on
social media are talking about their
diet and they might say like oh i'm
dieting you know as
a male on you know sixteen hundred
calories or fifteen hundred calories or
for a female dieter um
who you know is saying you know i'm
dying on you know eleven hundred twelve
hundred calories i think there's a
knee-jerk reaction to see that number
and say
damn that's not a lot of food that
sounds bad
and
in fitness it's become more and more
common to kind of crank that up several
notches and be like if you're dieting on
you know
1180 calories a day as a relatively
small person uh you know
your
coach whoever
recommended that is an absolute piece of
trash definitely stupid and almost
certainly a bad person
and i think there are pretty obvious
incentives kind of built into fitness
to reinforce that knee-jerk reaction i
think you'll see a lot of coaches who
will say
hey all my clients eat a ton
and they're losing fat very very rapidly
so why aren't you you know like it's
kind of a marketing
angle of like
you know my biggest problem with my fat
loss clients they can't get all the food
down they're eating so much and i mean
we're trying to get you know extra candy
and snickers bars just to get the
calories in uh that's an exaggeration
obviously but you can see what i'm
getting at there's this natural kind of
knee-jerk reaction when you see low
calories uh to kind of say oh man that's
irresponsible it's certainly dangerous
and definitely inadvisable but
i think it's important you know i've
talked in the past about how there are
benefits to a slow rate of weight loss
that is an approach that i feel pretty
strongly about in most contexts i think
uh slow and
sustainable rates of weight loss are
generally pretty
pretty good i've also talked in some
contexts about some of the challenges
that occur when you have very low energy
availability so when you've got acutely
a very large energy deficit so i've
talked about this in ways that might be
thought to reinforce some of those
knee-jerk reactions but i think it's
really important to
take a step back
and contextualize some of these low
calorie numbers right so if you were to
go and look at
the literature in the clinical nutrition
space
so more clinically oriented studies
looking at weight loss programs in
people who have obesity
it's really not that uncommon to see
diets prescribed that are
800 900 maybe a thousand calories per
day and like i said this is often being
prescribed to people with obesity whose
body mass can can often be you know
upwards of 100 kilograms right so
it's not hard to find instances in the
clinical nutrition literature of someone
who is 110 kilograms and they're being
put on an 800 900 calorie diet uh and in
fact i wouldn't just say you can find it
i would say
it's quite common uh like
there are certain areas of the
literature where that's almost kind of
the default lever that you pull right
just i mean just pull up the old pubmed
machine and type in vlcd yeah and see
what meets you yeah so i want to be
really clear about this i'm not
presenting that as like a model for
success i'm not saying like oh you want
to lose weight whatever the context is
just eat like eight nine hundred
calories a day it's plenty
but
i think it's important when you see
people talking about like oh my god if
you go under 1200 calories for a brief
period of time that is totally dangerous
no matter what that in and of itself is
not necessarily an evidence-based
statement it is contradictory relative
to the clinical nutrition uh literature
so
of course any time you're talking about
energy intake you have to look very
specifically at the context in which a
person is dieting you know some people
are going to be able to handle lower
calorie targets than others in a very
safe very effective way
but but i just wanted to kind of
reiterate the fact that you know when
when you see some of these lower calorie
intakes you know we've had people who
use macro factor for example who say i
mean we have safeguards in place where
you have to override kind of a lower
threshold for for calorie
recommendations but we have seen people
who say like hey
can you take a look at my macro or
calorie recommendations they seem low
and will look at it and be like well
you know based on the rate of weight
loss you've
selected as your goal those calories got
to come from somewhere right and so if
we're talking about trying to lose
a kilogram of fat a week for example we
got to find a way
to make a deficit of
at least you know 9 400 calories and
there's only seven days in a week right
so the daily deficit in order to make
that math work is gonna have to be big
and then you factor in the fact
that
when you are restricting calories to
anywhere close to that degree we often
see reductions in total daily energy
expenditure so it's not just where do i
find 9 400 calories it's where do i find
9 400 calories plus
the drop in total daily energy
expenditure that's likely to occur so
it's important when you look at calorie
numbers uh to not have a knee-jerk
reaction about what is an appropriate
intake uh it's important to consider
what is the body composition of the
individual what is their body size what
is their goal what is the intended rate
of weight loss and then you can kind of
contextualize the number from there yeah
i think also people are given
maybe
slightly unrealistic expectations of
how many calories they can eat to
achieve a certain body composition or a
certain physique
because
like energy needs are
variable just like everything else uh
and on social media
generally people who are at an extreme
end of the bell curve are the ones who
get more attention um you know because
they're they're outliers and uh
one might argue inherently more
interesting and so like you see this
with strength for example like if if you
follow a lot of powerlifting pages on
social media you'll see people who
aren't incredibly big squat you know six
seven hundred pounds and you know it's
it's like oh here's this person who's
not even the best in the world who's way
stronger than you so like this is this
is a normal a normal ass thing that
they're doing it's like oh no like
there's bigger freaks out there than
this person but like this person's also
a [ __ ] freak like you know that's
um
and i think a lot of new lifters don't
fully understand that like just
how variable strength potential is and i
think i think it's the same thing with
uh with energy needs like
um
we we talked about that poncer study um
looking at the relationship between lean
body mass and uh an energy expenditure
um over the life span
and like you can you can look at the
scatter plots in that study like at a
given at a given level of lean body mass
there could be people who
you know their daily energy needs are
like six seven hundred calories over the
average and some people six seven
hundred calories under the average but i
think on social media
posts will get traction if someone's
like [ __ ] shredded and they're like i
look like this and i still eat 3 400
calories a day and it's just like yeah
good for you buddy like that's that's
really cool but like
that's not gonna that's not gonna be the
experience of most people right um
and i mean like we've talked about this
like how
how little you were eating to get
absolutely peeled for your last show
we've talked with eric helms about this
as well like dude a lot of natural
bodybuilders to get absolutely peeled
for the last like
month or two of their cut they're not
eating much of anything yeah i remember
talking to helms and i i was kind of
like
embarrassed about it but i was like
honestly i got in really good shape this
last time but
i ate a calorie intake that you're not
supposed to eat based on everything i've
heard and he's like oh no that's the
secret that's the trick yeah you know
like i'm paraphrasing he's like yeah
when i started doing that i started
getting leaner but no so i i think what
you just said is very interesting like
you felt embarrassed by it yeah and and
you know as a responsible person you
probably didn't want to put that out in
the world right you probably didn't want
to say like
hey this is the size dude i am and
here's how little i was eating to look
like this because
you know
you're probably aware that people would
take that
not as an n equals one experience but as
advice and you don't necessarily want to
put out in the world like this is how
little you should be eating right and so
i think there's a filtering mechanism
where people who can eat way more than
average and still lose weight get
disproportionately more airtime and
people who have to eat a normal amount
to lose weight or less than average to
lose weight
generally if they talk about it it's
going to get less attention and they're
probably just going to be less likely to
talk about it in general and you're
going to get
owned if you talk about it right like if
if i go out there and i'm like oh yeah
here's my calorie intake people be like
that's stupid that's irresponsible it's
way too low yeah like yeah there's
there's a cost to putting that out there
right and and so i think all of those
things together
lead people to have a
unrepresentative idea of what normal
energy needs are for weight loss and
also
to
not have any concept of what energy
needs for weight loss might be for
someone whose daily energy expenditure
is like lower than would be predicted by
the equations like
dude i'm
still somewhere in the neighborhood of
240. i'm reasonably active and i'm
cutting on
cutting pretty slow on a little under 2
200 calories per day if i if i bumped it
up to
losing
a kilo a week i think i think i would be
on like 1400 calories a day or something
like that
um
which like
losing a kilo a week that's not a
ridiculous rate of weight loss that that
would be less than one percent of my
body weight per week right and i think
that a lot of people would bulk at
someone
my size
eating 1400 calories per day but like
that would be a reasonable rate of
weight loss i still have plenty of
weight to lose and that's about what i
would need to eat to lose weight at that
rate
um
and like i don't know i i do think that
my energy expenditure relative to my
body size is a little bit lower than
average but like i'm not an outlier like
that's
uh
that is comfortably within the realm of
normal
and uh i i think people just aren't
exposed to that yeah and so once again i
want to clarify my general approach um
if we just throw context out the window
my general approach to dieting is take
it slow
you know try not to have an enormous
caloric deficit day in and day out you
know try to be mindful of energy
availability that way you know there are
positive effects you know keeping
calories a little bit higher very
positive for things like satiety
energy level uh essential fatty acid
intake management of sex hormones uh you
know maintaining muscle maintaining
performance throughout the cut uh
potentially having a more sustainable
approach that will be
uh that will be better for long-term
maintenance once you've achieved the the
weight loss you wish to achieve there
are all sorts of upsides to trying to
keep your calories as high as you
feasibly can during a diet i mean that's
the whole reason i'm not trying to lose
tequila exactly yeah so i don't want it
to seem like i'm saying everyone should
be eating 800 calories that's not the
case and in some cases that would be
inadvisable and potentially deleterious
but the idea that it is wildly
irresponsible for anyone to go over
whatever the number is that week 1200
1300 1400 the idea that you can't go
below this number for any period of time
in any context is not really compatible
with the clinical weight loss literature
and i don't think a lot of people know
that
uh moving on i've got another one
i wanted to talk about so a really
common thing uh
is the idea that um
as we get older our protein needs go up
a little bit so so we should be shooting
for more protein per day
and more protein per meal as well that's
a really common thing that's out there
in the fitness world
and uh you know helms recently and mass
covered
a review paper on this topic and i think
there are a lot of misconceptions about
age and protein intake which is why i
wanted to kind of cover it in this
segment i've never been one to go out
there and really aggressively push
you know huge bumps in protein intake as
in individual ages but i have kind of
left wiggle room for it here and there
when discussing protein intake and i
think it's important to
contextualize
what the recommendations actually look
like in the literature
so first of all there is a review paper
by
i think it's
paulson and colleagues my font is very
small here i think paulson and
colleagues anabolic resistance of muscle
protein turnover comes in various shapes
and sizes so
a lot they have a comment here about you
know bumping up
protein as a result of aging
and it says
specifically protein intake should be
increased above the current rda to be
closer to 1.2 grams per kilogram per day
exercise resistance exercise in
particular seems to drastically increase
the dietary amino acid sensitivity of
older muscle to
protein ingestion and so the idea here
is when you see a lot of these papers on
pubmed that say hey when you get older
you need more protein per serving more
protein per day
in many instances they have baked in the
assumption that you are not exercising
regularly or lifting weights uh and
there and more specifically they're
saying you need to bump your protein
from 0.8 grams per kilogram to like
1.2 grams per kilogram which most people
in the fitness world are probably
closer to 2.2 than they are to 1.2 in
many cases it's not necessarily required
but
if anything i think people in our
area of the fitness world tend to air
toward higher rather than lower protein
intake so it's really important to keep
in mind that second part of that quote
which is that resistance exercise seems
to really drastically alter this
relationship between age and protein
needs especially when we're talking
about in the
30s 40s and 50s in terms of age well i i
don't even
i don't even necessarily know that
resistance exercise is required like i
i'm obviously not arguing that it's that
it's a bad thing but the the whole idea
of anabolic resistance to uh protein
feeding with age
came from a couple studies out of i
believe the us and canada where
um like both of those are car cultures
and
daily step counts tend to be pretty low
rates of uh
rates of sedentariness tend to be pretty
high
um
and then i don't have the
i don't have the citation on hand and i
don't remember the author but there was
a group out of either belgium or the
netherlands i believe netherlands that
uh they tried to replicate that and they
they didn't but you know they were
dealing with people who were just
generally more active had higher daily
step counts weren't necessarily i don't
think um
taking part in purposeful intense
exercise but you know they were dudes in
their 60s and 70s who were just still
moving around quite a bit because
you know their
the way their cities are designed
requires them to move around a fair bit
um and that seemed to be sufficient to
ameliorate uh so-called anabolic
resistance so it it it doesn't even
necessarily seem to be that like
a like resistance training needs to be
applied to uh
to ameliorate this it seems to be that
anabolic resistance is a
confluence of age and sedentariness but
if you
just have age but aren't sedentary that
that that seems to to go a long way
towards ameliorating it
yeah and so there's a review paper by
moore
uh
where
he kind of identifies some of the
factors
that lead to this anabolic resistance
in
older individuals
and one of the things that's tricky is a
lot of times as we age our activity
level goes down so it can be very hard
to separate out when we just look at
older individuals as a cross-sectional
perspective who already are less active
than they used to be how much of this is
related to aging and how much is related
to the drop in activity level but
the
some of the factors that are thought to
predispose this anabolic resistance
talking about chronic inflammation
potentially
reduced capillary capacity or
you know vasodilatory capacity so
the capillarity of tissues and also the
responsiveness of the vascular tissue
itself
also potentially some attenuated muscle
uptake
when it comes to amino acids but what's
really important is when you start
looking at a lot of these potential
predisposing factors
many of them are very directly
influenced by exercise and physical
activity and in moore's review paper
which i think helms did a great job
covering uh it i don't want to
paraphrase uh and oversimplify too much
but it largely makes the case that you
know we're talking about a you know a 52
year old uh
lifetime lifter who's still training
hard they probably look look more
similar to
in terms of protein response a 25 year
old lifter than someone who is their age
but totally sedentary and inactive and
not training uh you know the the act of
you know
doing regular physical activity and
training regularly seems to
attenuate
if not
largely abolish a lot of these things
associated with anabolic resistance so
uh we get asked a lot of questions from
people who are
in their 40s and their 50s and sometimes
in their 60s as well and they say
how much do i need to bump my protein
because of age
and these are people who are extremely
fit they're very active they're training
like crazy and in most cases the answer
is probably somewhere between not at all
and maybe a tiny bit
and this is something that is you know
if you've been following the stronger by
science cinematic universe
when you see papers
about anabolic resistance
sometimes you'll see them talking about
age but also obesity and excess
adiposity
one of the
ideas that we really leaned into when we
were talking about p ratios and whether
or not uh obesity or excess adiposity
would attenuate
the potential for hypertrophy you know
this idea of anabolic resistance came up
and you know we push back pretty hard on
the concept that someone who is you know
has obesity but is exercising regularly
is active and is doing regular intense
training we're like man if you look at
the mechanisms here
it's very likely that they're going to
be you know rescuing that ability to
respond quite well to dietary amino
acids and so this particular review
paper was focusing on aging but there's
in my opinion pretty clear translation
to what we were getting at which is the
fact that if you look at anabolic
resistance in someone with obesity who's
totally sedentary totally untrained that
probably isn't very representative of
anabolic resistance in someone with
obesity who is quite physically active
and training regularly so
important stuff to highlight there
one last thing i want to mention very
briefly i know you want to get to some q
a questions um in the past i've been
pretty hard on cardio which seems to
contradict my current uh road to athens
but i think it's important to
contextualize that so a lot of times
when we talk about cardio it's in two
specific contexts one is i get a lot of
questions about cardio during contest
prep for physique athletes and i think
there's a
serious tendency to overdo cardio during
physique prep
and the downsides of that can be
pretty rough a lot of times it can
take people to a spot where their hunger
is is really not very manageable they're
tapping into their ability to recover
from their resistance training uh
there's you know potentially heightened
uh
possibility of lean mass loss you know
when you're talking about contest prep
where
losses and lean mass are are just kind
of part of the process in most cases
it's a very precarious physiological
state where i think overdoing cardio a
little bit can really come back to bite
you it's a bit of a double-edged sword
but
the other context where we talk about
cardio a lot is on the topic of
concurrent training and the interference
effect and a lot of times i think cardio
its potential impact
in blunting strength or hypertrophy is
very overblown we've talked about that
previously quite a few times on the
podcast but
when you talk about the interference
effect with concurrent training first of
all the effect on power is much more
notable
than the effect on strength or
hypertrophy
which is a really important thing to
keep in mind
the other thing is when you look at the
volume the frequency of cardio in
studies on the interference effect and
concurrent training it's usually
way higher than what you're seeing like
we'll get someone who asks hey can i do
this much cardio and it's like a tenth
of what's going on in those concurrent
training studies so in most cases uh the
whole interference effect you know as
long as you're not pushing pretty high
volumes and pretty high frequencies of
cardio it's usually not a particularly
noteworthy factor
now
outside of those those two contexts
physique prep and concurrent training
and interference effect just looking at
exercise and its potential impact on
just general health and longevity
i'll link to a paper here by
grimo and colleagues i think that's how
you pronounce it but
the list of mechanisms
by which regular exercise can attenuate
the aging process and promote longevity
is absolutely insane i mean there's got
to be 35 different bullet points here
related to
uh the brain the vascular system the
heart
the liver
i mean uh
the i mean the management of systemic
inflammation the management of autophagy
over time
the number of mechanisms by which
regular engagement with some amount of
cardiovascular exercise
can impact positively your health and
longevity uh it it's kind of one of
those things i'll be honest i kind of
forgot how cool exercise was if i'm
being completely honest because i mean
you might yeah you just kind of take it
for granted you take it for granted and
you get so locked into training that you
forget about exercising so like when i
think about
you know ever since probably like my
third year of undergrad for me
i got over the
absolutely insane benefits associated
with exercise and just like marveling
over how
powerful it can be and then i got like
tunnel vision on training sets reps you
know frequency optimizing hypertrophy
i got so focused on
strength and hypertrophy i forgot about
just the
generalized insane benefits of exercise
and so i think it's important to point
those out sometimes when you know a lot
of times people in the strength world or
the physique world they view
cardiovascular exercise or aerobic
exercise i guess as something that is uh
an opposing force you know relative to
what they're trying to achieve i think
that idea of creating this kind of
duality or this dichotomy where you're
either focused on strength and
hypertrophy or engaging in aerobic
exercise
i i don't think that that's a
particularly constructive way to look at
it uh and the benefits of just doing a
little bit of exercise are are pretty
profound
even if you separate them out from
weight loss or a variety of other
reasons why people might do it so i
think it's important as someone who has
you know said a lot of things about
minimizing cardio in certain scenarios i
don't want that to seem as if you know
i don't want everyone to do what i did
and take exercise for granted because
it's a pretty special thing when you
look at
the just broad spectrum of physiological
impacts so you mentioned uh you
mentioned the interference effect there
yes um
so i'm gonna lop a bomb into this
conversation real quick oh boy and i
will i will admit on the outset uh this
the
study i'm about to talk about i haven't
read it yet sometimes someone sent this
to me yesterday um so i i just simply
haven't had
an opportunity to read it yet but it
looks like it might be kind of spicy uh
hot new concurrent training
meta-analysis just dropped three days
ago uh-oh um
and again this was just sent to me
yesterday so all i've done is read the
abstract i'm being transparent about
this i don't know
all of the details of this but
but
uh i i could see this being contentious
because it seems to be implying that the
interference effect
actually completely
wow
so here's i'm just going to read the
results here
i thought you were going to
contradict my perspective but you are
doubling down hard yeah you're pushing
it i'm saying
that you are being a coward and still
implying that the interference effect
may exist when uh
no so okay here's here's just the the
results from the abstract of this study
and and we can link this in the show
notes and if uh if anyone listening to
this gets around to reading the full
text before i do i would be very
interested to know your take on it
but here are the results a total of 43
studies were included the estimated
standardized mean difference based on
the random effects model were
uh negative
0.06 for strength negative 0.28 for
explosive strength and that was the only
effect that was significant and negative
0.01
for
muscle hypertrophy which is essentially
no effect
attenuation of explosive strength
was more pronounced when concurrent
training was performed within the same
session than when sessions were
separated by at least three hours so
when
uh explosive training and endurance
training were
performed in different sessions
separated by at least three hours there
wasn't a significant attenuation of
explosive performance
and no significant effects were found
for the other moderators i.e type of
aerobic training running versus cycling
frequency of concurrent training more or
less than five weekly sessions training
status untrained versus trained
and mean age less than 40 or greater
than 40 years old and then this is their
conclusion concurrent aerobic and
strength training does not compromise
muscle hypertrophy and maximal strength
development however explosive strength
gains may be attenuated especially when
aerobic and strength training are
performed in the same session
these results appear to be independent
of the type of aerobic training
frequency of concurrent training
training status and age
so
so it's
the effect sizes if you ignore
statistical significance do kind of
still kind of reinforce that concept
that you know power is what's largely
being impacted
uh and then strengthen hypertrophy it
sounds like they're saying the these
might be this is saying strength and
hypertrophy aren't impacted at all yeah
yeah well that's interesting we'll have
to uh we'll have to dig into that that's
spicy man i i think i'm probably going
to review this for the january issue of
mass unless mike beats me to it nice but
uh
yeah man that's
that's not necessarily what i expected
to see
cool well yeah so like i said um there
are some ass some scenarios where you
want to keep an eye on your cardio
volume and frequency um for
context specific reasons uh but
generally speaking i don't want it to
seem like i haven't just
overall anti-cardio vibe that i'm
putting out
now i'm going to expose myself here for
calling this the morning i feel
compelled to tell you it's 2 52 p.m
uh
the floor is yours uh as many q a
questions as you wish to cover
you're welcome and uh and then i will be
playing us out today yeah
you know i think it'll be fine i just
need to get some cookies baked before 4
p.m and i am quick at baking cookies and
one thing i'll note is unless unless
that meta-analysis i referenced um
just really blows me out of the water i
i do still think the the interference
effect is real just throwing that out
there um
don't necessarily assume that
my actual position on the topic is
identical to
uh
the abstract of that study i just read
or the words that literally came out of
your mouth
i said that when you were reading i said
that it's spicy and they were lob and
bombs yeah um that's the thing though
with knowledge bombs yes with
meta-analyses um man a lot of people
because they're you know at the top of
the hierarchy of evidence you think oh
easy you know it's it's right there very
straightforward
man you really gotta dig in when you're
critically reading a meta-analysis uh
you got to get really into the details
so we'll have to report back on that
yeah the the thing that came to mind for
me was uh
just based on the abstract it looked it
looks like they looked at aerobic
training
frequency as a moderator variable but
not like total minutes per week
and i
my my hunch is that that would be a
pretty large effect like you know if
you're if you're doing cardio five days
per week but it's like 20 minutes per
session who cares but if you're doing
warming up yeah if you're doing cardio
five days per week and it's like an hour
per session
i kind of assume that that's going to
negatively impact strength gains yeah
anyway um
yeah yeah some q and a's these should
all be pretty quick i think uh starting
with facebook
uh william lim jr uh asks inter
incremental progression pros and cons a
thought experiment if i'm in a hurry to
get somewhere in my fitness journey what
would happen or if i'm not in a hurry to
get somewhere in my fitness journey what
would happen if i just progress
incrementally by half or even a quarter
of a pound per week and concentrate on
good form technique and contraction
for example i start with just the bar on
press and keep adding half a pound each
week
seems like it would be a lot friendlier
to join slash connective tissue and at
some point in the future i'll catch up
with those chasing numbers
is there too much to miss out on the
huge usual progression models
and i i see where he's coming from with
this question like basically
if you're kind of doing a linear
progression
why stick with five or ten pound jumps
when you could just kind of micro load
from the get-go
and the thing is i could see that being
inefficient but still effective if
you're
completely untrained and just getting
into lifting um
but i i think that it will be
yeah i think that there's probably a
middle ground there where
you know like let's say you
start squatting and or you start
deadlifting and the most you can
deadlift your first time with good form
is uh
let's say 185 pounds or something like
that but
you know that's that's your initial max
because you're not good at dead lifting
um and you know your your muscles your
connective tissue
everything
would be capable of say deadlifting
uh somewhere in the low 300s but like
you currently just aren't good at
deadlifting um
so the the initial
phase of training where you're doing a
linear progression just adding weight to
the bar week to week
you are to some degree trying to
condition your muscles in connective
tissue to
avoid injury or reduce your injury risk
but like largely you're just you're just
learning the exercise and i think that
from a kind of health and injury risk
reduction perspective
even if you're using a faster rate of
progression say adding 5 or 10 pounds to
the bar every week on that deadlift
you're still probably in good shape
mostly due to the fact that
you are
at all points along that continuum until
things start getting legitimately hard
until you've actually learned to
deadlift pretty well
you are
staying well below what those tissue
tolerances are like your hamstrings your
glutes your spinal erectors
are capable of producing more force
than they're doing to deadlift 185
you're just not good at deadlifting yet
so i
i think that i i understand where you're
coming from with kind of a
connective tissue being nice to your
joints type perspective
uh but i
really don't think you need to be that
conservative and then from a more
long-term perspective
um
you know the the variability in
individual strength from workout to
workout
is is more than half a pound
so
you know i i think ultimately you'll end
up
hitting the same wall that anyone else
would um and still needing to move on to
something else at approximately the same
strength levels when you otherwise would
have needed to
but you know you're
maybe
extending out a process that otherwise
would have taken
three to six months into being a process
that takes like five years so
um
yeah i see where you're coming from but
i
don't really see any notable upsides to
that approach but
depending how much you value efficiency
maybe some some clear downsides uh the
one thing i will note is i i am kind of
a fan of micro loading if for
um for lifts where you just can't put as
much weight on the bar so
you know if you're doing like curls
tricep extensions uh or even for um just
naturally weaker male lifters and a lot
of female lifters like the overhead
press
you know a five pound jump can can be a
pretty big jump so getting getting some
plates that let you load
you know
two and a half pound jumps or one kilo
jumps or even like uh one pound half
kilo jump something like that i i think
that can be productive because
functionally
like a one kilo jump uh for
a curl might be the same as like a two
and a half three even five kilo jump for
a deadlift so you know i think you can
scale this to kind of what your actual
loading capacity is on an exercise by
exercise basis but
you know for the big lifts at least i i
certainly don't think you uh really gain
much by going that slow
uh moving on jarrett wade brumet
asks um
going off of the study you shared
earlier this week
i'd really like to hear what the
literature says about what the general
public should do to improve the
likelihood of maintaining weight loss i
i think the study he's referring to
was a study we shared uh
from the instagram account which was
previously a mass research brief
on
resistance training independently
reducing visceral fat
even in the absence of a
purposeful caloric deficit
i assume i i assume that's what's being
referenced
or maybe a better question what's the
literature say to be predicting factors
of regain that people should address
when attempting weight loss maybe this
was about something you posted i don't
know
whatever uh basically what what factors
um predict successful weight loss
maintenance i i think that's essentially
what's being asked here
um and so i the the first place my brain
went to answer this question was to the
national weight control registry what
that is uh it's it's an american thing
and you can apply to be a part of the
registry if you're at least 18 years old
and have lost at least 30 pounds and
have maintained it for at least a year
so
it's essentially a thing that you can
just
opt into and and that is one thing to
note it's not a perfectly representative
sample of everyone who's lost weight
it's a representative sample of everyone
who's lost weight and knows what the
national weight control registry is and
wants to tell you about it and wants to
tell you about it so you know this may
not be the perfect sample for answering
this question but i i think it's
one of the better ones that exists yeah
so with that caveat out of the way um
within the national weight control
registry
uh they say there is a variety in how
national weight control registry members
keep the weight off uh most report
continuing to maintain a low-calorie
low-fat diet and doing high levels of
activity
and then just some notes 78 percent eat
breakfast every day 75 weigh themselves
at least once a week 62 percent watch
less than 10 hours of tv per week and 90
exercise on average at least one hour
per day
i don't know the degree to which all of
those things are necessarily causal i
don't necessarily know that a low-fat
diet is better than a low-carb diet for
maintaining weight loss i don't
necessarily think that eating breakfast
every day is important so keep in mind
those are those are correlative things
not causal things people in the national
weight control registry those are the
things that they report doing
um but one of the things from
really every line of research i've seen
looking at weight loss maintenance that
seems to be
a very important factor is exercise um
you know you were just talking a second
ago about how how cool exercises and all
of its benefits and i think that
exercise gets kind of a bad rap in some
circles for its impact on weight loss
because
the research that's out there looking at
the impact of just exercise on
weight loss itself
isn't that promising like if you take
people uh you know just pluck them out
of the general population and say hey
you're gonna start exercising like
doesn't matter if it's high intensity
interval training doesn't matter if it's
cardio doesn't matter if it's resistance
training
whatever generally what you see is like
uh maybe they'll lose a couple pounds
but not many uh it doesn't seem to be an
effective
exercise only interventions don't seem
to be
effective standalone interventions for
a large amount of long-term weight loss
but
exercise does seem to be very important
for weight loss maintenance um
and i think that there are some reasons
for that
one is uh actually
i could i could talk about this for a
long time but i think the biggest reason
why exercise is important for weight
loss maintenance um you know on top of
it just generally being good for you is
exercise seems to regulate your hunger
pretty well so
um you have
kind of homeostatic
uh weight mechanisms within your body
where
if everything is working appropriately
even without tracking your your
nutritional intake
on average for most people if you're
reasonably active
your
felt caloric needs should
comport pretty well with your actual
caloric needs for weight maintenance
um
but if you're reasonably sedentary those
homeostatic weight regulatory factors
can kind of get out of whack and so
basically you just wind up being
hungrier than you need to be for the
actual
number of calories that you're expending
per day so
um
you know i i think a lot of people who
lose weight and then keep it off do
also do some degree of purposeful
nutritional regulation whether that's a
particular type of diet whether that's
counting calories like there's a lot of
um there's a lot of methods people go
with to lose the weight and and keep it
off on the nutritional side of things
but exercise just makes all of that work
better because if you're exercising and
you're in a small calorie deficit you'll
probably be less hungry than if you're
not exercising any and you're in a small
calorie deficit and then when you've
lost a lot of weight and you're trying
to keep it off
maintenance when you're when you've lost
a lot of fat leptin levels are low
hunger is probably going to be elevated
exercise can kind of take the edge off
of that and help those homeostatic
uh hunger regulatory factors just work
better
so yeah
you know reducing sedentary time so a
lot of these people report not watching
a ton of television i think that's
important uh 75 weigh themselves at
least once per week you know i i think
uh that kind of goes to the to the adage
of what gets measured gets managed like
keeping an awareness of your weight so
it doesn't start creeping back up i
think that's probably pretty important
uh but i i think if you were trying to
narrow it down to just one thing um
exercise seems to be like
regularly exercising and not being
sedentary seems to be uh quite important
yeah and if i could add one thing to
kind of tie some concepts together
because i think if people are taking
notes and they should be i often say
people should take notes when they
listen to the show
they'll notice we've said a few things
that on the surface sound to be a bit
contradictory so
we talked about how the interference
effect doesn't have a notable impact on
hypertrophy we've also talked about how
generally speaking being you know having
a high physical activity level can help
regulate hunger
in a caloric deficit in the context of
weight loss
but
when i was talking about cardio during
prep one of the things i kind of
mentioned as an aside was
potentially
how that can impact hunger responses in
people doing physique prep
and i think it's really important to
highlight that the distinction there is
the physiological context of doing
contest prep so
if the concurrent training literature
was all done in people who were four and
a half percent body fat and training
their ass off and in a caloric deficit
i think we might see something going on
with hypertrophy yeah
and
one of the things we see with
key drivers of hyperphagia the really
pronounced hunger that occurs
in you know physique or bodybuilding
prep one of the key drivers of
hyperphagia is the loss of fat free mass
and so that's why you have to take these
c these statements about the
interference effect and the relationship
between physical activity and hunger
those are generally speaking you know
the more generalizable approaches to to
those topics or kind of conclusions
there but when you put those into the
context of someone who is
doing contest prep shredded caloric
deficit
all their hormones are out of whack
their hypothalamus is completely checked
out and they're overdoing their cardio
now we see a slightly different response
to how that excess or that excessive
cardio can impact their hunger
management so i just wanted to i wanted
to make sure whenever i'm listening to a
podcast and something at the beginning
and something at the end seem
contradictory and they don't draw it out
for me i get very frustrated so
the context the physiological
uh
aspects that come with physique prep
really do make it a very unique uh
context to talk about
yes i agree
all right moving on to uh reddit there
was a question from no goat
6887
um
and
this question was very long and then at
the end he added an edit edit i could
have made this whole post shorter and
just asked what's the most i can get
done in the least amount of time uh and
this was in the context of resistance
training so basically asking um
you know if you don't want to
necessarily train for optimal to get as
strong as possible or build as much
muscle as as quickly as you can um you
know what can you get away with to still
get a lot of the benefits while uh
trying to maximize efficiency so you
know most most results with the the
least uh
time and effort investment possible
um
and so
this
i it wasn't clear whether this was
specifically about strength or a
combination of strength and hypertrophy
uh for strength there was a
recent study by uh
one of the stronger by science coaches
pack on the minimal effective dose of
training for strength development um
if you just plug that exact phrase into
google i'm sure his paper will come up
and he previously authored a brief
meta-analysis on that as well so you you
can check out those two things for a
combination of strength and hypertrophy
um
i i think what i'm about to say will
will get the job done pretty well to get
you i don't know maybe 70 percent of the
gains you would be capable of achieving
in
minimal time so
first off i think you should be trading
training with pretty moderate loads and
in moderate rep ranges so i'm gonna
operationally define that as sets of
five to 15 reps you should mostly be
doing compound lifts because you're
going to be training more musculature
per
unit of time invested in per set you're
doing
frequency can be fairly low
one to two times per muscle group per
week
you don't have to do a ton of sets about
two to three sets per exercise you know
if you wanted to maximize hypertrophy
long term volume would probably need to
creep up but to get reasonably large you
don't need insane levels of training
volume
but you should have a pretty high level
of effort per set so training
to failure or within a rep or two of
failure so i think the most stripped
down version of this um
is so
actually this is exactly what i tell
people to do when they come to me with
this question
they say like hey look i don't want to
spend much time training at all maybe
like an hour total per week
what should i do so
you're going to train twice a week one
day you're going to do squat overhead
press and either rows or pull-ups
whichever one you want to do
and
the other day you're going to do
deadlift bench press and either rows or
pull-ups whichever one you didn't do the
first day
um
for the squat bench press deadlift
overhead press you're gonna do three
sets you're gonna take them all
basically to failure or until you feel
like your form is about to just
completely go to [ __ ]
um and you're gonna start with a load
that you can do for
about 15 reps and if you're gonna air
air a little bit low if you do
you know 16 18 reps the first week
that's totally fine uh and then
week over week you just go up by five or
ten pounds and just try to maintain as
many reps as possible as the weights go
up
uh and then eventually when you hit a
five rep max and you know like oh when i
go up and wait next week i'm gonna do
fewer than five reps you just start over
so you go back to whatever weight you
did the first time so you know you use
an app use a spreadsheet keep a training
log like make note of your weights and
performances over time
so just start over and just try to beat
the number of reps you did all the way
back up so the the weight you started
with that you could initially do for 15
reps if now you can do it for 18 cool
that's progress and that's also more
than 15 reps so the next time you start
back over just just skip that first week
and start with something that
corresponds to about 15 reps and same
same thing repeat the process build back
up and try to hit a heavier five rep max
in your kind of final week of this build
up than you did previously if you do
that cool you made progress you're
stronger and just start over again
so that's what you're going to do with
squat bench deadlift overhead press
two to three sets really go all out
every time and then for uh for rows and
pull-ups pull-downs just you know any
any upper-back training um
i i mean i think just do like three or
four sets and and just hammer them um
no one's gonna ask what your one rep max
row is uh
so you know you're just you're just
trying to crank it out get the work get
the work in uh and i don't think you
need to think about those too terribly
hard if you can maintain
more than 15 reps over three or four
sets add some more weight to the bar uh
if you guess too heavy and by the last
set you're you're not able to complete
five or six reps take a little weight
off the bar but
you know just just really get after it
for three or four sets and you'll be
good so
um
six six total exercises two training
sessions per week
um
you know that's not gonna that's not
gonna make you the most muscular or the
strongest person in the world but
you should be able to get all of that
done in about 30 minutes per session
and uh you know
most people should be able to make
pretty decent gains from that so that
that is
exactly what i would recommend uh
in the situation that you're describing
and then this last one by
needman nademan
uh how big of a deal are the negative
effects of nsaids i understand they can
blunt hypertrophy but to what degree
is the occasional mid-hangover ibuprofen
really killing my gains
and for this one i
i kind of think that the negative impact
of nsaids on strength and hypertrophy i
think that's largely been overblown
um most of the studies that
are investigating that so so just one
general thing about research is that
once a body of literature is developed
pretty well then you start getting
more nuanced studies that are kind of
trying to paint in the details so
for example maybe a dose response type
study but to justify something like that
generally the early studies in a body of
literature are are
slightly extreme to verify that a
potential effect exists that warrants
looking into further so in the case of
the nsaid literature
this is something that gets talked about
a lot but there's there's not actually a
ton of studies on this
uh and and the studies that are out
there do tend to show
that
using nsaids during resistance training
does blunt hypertrophy outcomes
and some of the effects
are are pretty notable so it might
reduce hypertrophy by anywhere from
one-third to two-thirds of what you
could otherwise expect without nsaids um
so that that seems fairly notable but
the thing to keep in mind is the dosages
used in those studies for the nsaids are
quite high
um and generally they're either being
used every training day or every day
so
you know
i think people
hear that and they say like they
compartmentalize that is like oh nsaids
are bad i have a headache but i can't
take
an ibuprofen because that's gonna kill
my gains that's not what's being studied
it's looking at
like chronic long-term use of quite high
doses of nsaids so you know if you need
to take some nsaids just on a one-off
basis because
you know you got a joint ache you got a
headache you have a hangover like that's
i assume that's fine and most
importantly that hasn't been researched
um
so you know the stuff that's out there
shows that like ah there's there's maybe
a notable negative effect if you're
using a lot of this stuff very
consistently uh chronically
but i think that lower doses probably
not a huge deal um
and i think that occasional uses also
probably not a huge deal um
but
the like that's just not what the
research is looking at to this point
um
one thing to note as well is i think
that it's
largely reflective of like a hormetic
response so
hormesis is basically the idea that for
a particular
input
uh
the the input itself might exist on a
bell curve and there is an optimal level
of whatever that input is for the output
that you're interested in and it's it's
most
frequently hermesis is most most
generally comes up when you're talking
about uh like stress or
um
like like physiological stressors so in
this case we're talking about
inflammation and so
some degree of post-exercise
inflammation is beneficial for the
muscle remodeling and hypertrophy
response
and so if you really really blunt that
with high doses of nsaids now you're
kind of to one side of the hormetic
curve and you don't get the the
magnitude of outcome you're interested
in
if inflammation on the other hand is way
too high that can also have negative
effects so
there's been
either one or two studies looking at
nsaid usage in elderly people
or not elderly but older people doing
resistance training and in at least one
of those studies they found that nsaids
when paired with resistance training
actually improved hypertrophy outcomes
so older people tend to have higher
baseline levels of inflammation and it
it could be that they're to the other
side of that hormetic curve maybe
inflammation is too high and using some
insects to bring that down actually has
a beneficial effect so you know i i
think that ultimately
that's sort of the relationship you're
dealing with so there's a range of
inflammation that could be occurring and
you need some amount of it but not none
of it and not to the most of it so i
think if you're using low doses of
nsaids to knock down some sort of
inflammatory response a little bit
you're probably just shifting yourself
along that hormetic curve very slightly
it's probably not going to have that
much of an effect especially if it's
only used intermittently that is
that is my assumption i i think
most people
who aren't just using high doses of
nsaids every day probably just don't
even need to worry about it um
but again this body of literature is
relatively young and there haven't been
studies to kind of flesh out all of
those details dose response work etc so
um
at this point we don't know for sure but
but that is my supposition like most
most people probably don't need to worry
about it
the studies in older adults do you
happen to know if they were uh untrained
at the time of the study i think they
were because you know like we talked
about
we do expect you know systemic
inflammation to go up with age
regular
engage you know regularly engaging in
exercise and physical activity can
attenuate that age-related increase in
inflammation but is unlikely to blunt it
fully so that's an important thing to
keep in mind yes
okay so uh to play us out i'm going to
keep this very brief i'm going to close
with
simply a warning
there is
a misconception you know people talk
about fat bear week as if it's you know
cute and fun
but there are potentially
real world consequences of fat bear week
and i feel like a lot of a lot of
podcasts especially in fitness aren't
talking about this oh for sure which is
why i wanted to bring it up
so i saw a tweet uh by bbc their like
world account
and it was a bear and her crew they were
on the prowl in jackson hole wyoming
and the bear was grizzly 399 and
as many people know she's
her tagline is she's the most famous
brown bear mother in the world
she's a seven footer
uh seven feet tall
a very formidable bear she's had 20 cubs
in grand cubs in her life
and she was prowling through jackson
hole wyoming and i'm not an expert in
bear behavior but
it looked like she was there with a
purpose and i do suspect that there are
two things kind of under her skin first
of all
she is sick of getting completely
overlooked during fat bear week
second i think she's sick of not having
a real name you know like we talked
about in fat bear week half the bracket
was just a three digit number
grizzly399 grizzly is not a name it
needs to be like you know
samantha399 we need we need a name to go
with that three-digit number and she
seemed pissed you know so she can't she
brought her whole crew she was going
through jackson hole wyoming um and i
don't know what she was trying to do i
don't know if it was just intimidation i
don't know if she was looking for the
the county board of elections to kind of
you know let people know that she knows
what's going on with the votes
um but anyway
she could have been going to try to
actually officially change her name try
to find the county office for that i'm
not sure
but uh
it looked like she meant business in
this case they were able to talk her
down and to get her to peacefully return
home and leave the city which is good uh
no one harmed in the process but in
order to just kind of
stifle this and keep the peace i would
urge everyone uh to support a write-in
campaign next year in fat bear week i i
don't i don't think that's allowed for
grizzly399 well it
the postal service will deliver your
letters you can still write it in i mean
so i
consider myself something of a
constitutional scholar
and uh
one of
one of the one of the clauses in the uh
in whatever article is about the
executive branch that goes overlooked is
that uh the official fat bear is is a
dually elected position
and um
the the thing is you can only be elected
within the
nature preserve that you were born in
you have to be
a natural born citizen you can't be a
naturalized citizen and you certainly
can't be
you can't be a foreigner
and run for
official
and so
that's all going down at the cap my
preserve in alaska yeah which is notably
not in wyoming so
you know i i think our i think the
framers of the constitution knew what
they were doing they wanted to make sure
that we didn't have
foreign bears from wyoming from wyoming
sullying
the national office in alaska right
which was a very integral part of the
country in 1776
[Laughter]
so yeah i mean
you know if if you're
if you're trying to get someone on the
case to overturn this like
you're you're gonna you're gonna need to
appeal it all the way up to the supreme
court and you're gonna need to get some
intense judicial activism to completely
rewrite the constitution from the bench
uh so i mean good luck with that yeah
well one thing i know for certain is
that we're not gonna completely move on
from this and forget about it until fat
bear week next year i'm sure we're gonna
have uh more updates about this but
that does it for this episode of the
stronger by science podcast as always
thank you for joining us and one last
reminder uh november 22nd through
november 29th we've got our big annual
black friday sale for mass if you're not
sure yet if you want to check it out you
can look at the best of issue which is a
free pdf you can get an idea of what the
mass research review is all about so
thanks and we'll see you soon